we live in an increasingly urban world
busy lives on busy streets the hustle
and bustle of everyday life
but imagine if suddenly everything
stopped
the home suddenly empty and everything
was abandoned
[Applause]
throughout history there have been
hundreds of ghost towns
places abandoned for a range of reasons
in many instances abandonment is rapid
and locations transform abruptly from
being
live and in the present to being dead
and in the past
leaving behind broken but recognizable
remnants of life
and often a pervading sense of
melancholy
the abandonment of towns is nothing new
remnants of human presence have inspired
artists and poets dating back to ancient
times
whether romanticized or dreaded our
fascination with ghost towns carries on
to this day
creating a subculture of dark tourism
travelling to these abandoned sites can
take on the significance of a pilgrimage
especially where a location is
associated with death
travel agents offer day trips to
chernobyl for some the opportunity to
witness the aftermath of a nuclear
disaster
is too tempting to resist visitors also
flock to epicuen in argentina
a town semi-submerged after the dam
above it broke in 1985.
there are many other reasons why towns
are suddenly abandoned
one of them is war in june 1944
the waffen-ss murdered the entire
population of arador saglan
in occupied france a total of 642
men women and children the ruined
streets and homes
have remained untouched ever since a
memorial to the dead
on the other side of the channel in the
autumn of 1943 as britain prepared for
d-day
the residents of imber and wiltshire
were told that they had mere weeks to
leave their homes
as the ministry of defense needed places
for troop training and target practice
residents assumed that they'd be able to
return to their homes after the war
but in fact the ministry of defence
retained the village
imba is still used to this day for urban
warfare training
not all ghost towns have such violent
histories
all over the world practicalities such
as clean water
electricity and transport led to the
displacement of thousands of people
who sacrifice their homes schools and
businesses to enable other cities to
thrive
the village of kappel kellen in wales
was controversially vacated and then
flooded in 1965 to provide a water
reservoir for the city of liverpool
the action was and still is deeply
resented by nationalists in wales
furious that a welsh community paid such
a high price for england's gain
at times ghost towns represent a
cautionary tale
a reminder of how humanity's own actions
have also created a legacy of
uninhabitable landscapes
abandoned mining towns like gilman
colorado
heavily mined for silver lead and zinc
since the late 1800s
then ordered to vacate in 1984 due to
toxic pollutants that contaminated the
groundwater
to this day gilman remains unsafe and
off limits to the public
climate change too presents an
existential threat to the populations of
some towns and cities
floods wildfires weather and erosion
caused people to have to abandon their
homes all over the world
[Music]
the ancient civilization of harappa on
the indus river valley
was possibly a victim of climate change
around 1800 bce
when it was abandoned due to the
disruption of river systems
today the welsh village of fairborne is
facing an uncertain future
built on the coast in the mid-19th
century a large part of the village sits
below sea level
with levels rising due to climate change
defending the village is no longer
sustainable
the residents of fairborn are in danger
of becoming among the first uk citizens
to be displaced by climate change
are we witnessing the early days of a
new ghost town
what is the dark magic of ghost hounds
is it because they lure us they invite
us to briefly visit
our own demise or is it the thrill of
experiencing a dystopian landscape we're
familiar with from books and films
nobody in these abandoned communities
expected that this would happen to them
our lives homes and cities seem so
permanent
it's frightening to realize we are
largely powerless to prevent forces
acting at scale
perhaps we're drawn to these ghost towns
for a very simple and intimate reason
for the opportunity to imagine what if
this happened to me
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification
each time we upload a new video